the grammy's just two days away here in
las vegas but tonight another
star-studded event taking place over the
mgm grand garden it is called music
cares it's holding its in-person of the
year gala to raise money for the music
community in times of need sasha loftis
joining us there live from the red
carpet now with more hi sasha
[Music]
hey brian yes you caught us at just the
right time the person of the year event
tonight is honoring joni mitchell and
she actually just got here you can see
she's one of really the icons that are
here at this event tonight all to raise
money a really philanthropic event for
the music community as in times of need
of course through the pandemic this was
really an important
effort through the music care
organization now the red carpet has been
going on since about five o'clock last
about another hour you see joni mitchell
here we are expected to see people like
john legend and rita wilson who is on
the board of directors of music cares
this of course will be a silent auction
really their biggest fundraiser of the
year and it's really a great way to kick
off the grammys here in las vegas i
asked a lot of the people that i spoke
with here how excited they are to have
this event here in las vegas and a lot
of them said they hope it continues to
stay here in our city that it's really
just a great place to be and just
celebrate the biggest night of music
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now